では よろしくお願いします
これから五回に分けて
楽しみというテーマについてお話しします
楽しみという概念は 初期仏教
お釈迦様の教えからはどう見るべきかということ
それほど難しいテーマにはならないと思います
もうちょっと押してください
楽しみに飢えているということ
と だいたいどなたでもね
楽しみたいしね 楽しみ方も知りたいし
それは大変大事な問題だと思います
で 今日はこの 何でしたっけ
なぜ楽しめなくなったのかという
で 英語でWho robbed your smile?という
あなたの微笑みは誰が誰に盗まれたのかというね
我々人間というのはなんとなく笑えなくなってるんです
これが誰が盗んでいったのかということで話します
はい それで お釈迦様の教えからこの楽しむ智慧を見出すということでやります
生きるとは苦の上に成り立つと説かれてますね
一般的には それは仏教の知識ある方々はこれよく知ってることで
初期仏教でもよく言ってますよね
生きてる生きるっていうことは苦の上に成り立ってるんだと
はい 次押してください
パーリ語で それはドゥッヘ ローコー パティッティと
ローコーっていうのは世界のことを
生命のことをですね 生命っていうのは生きることなんですね
だからそれは苦しみの上に成り立っているんだと
で そう言われると 何はそれ？という感じになるんですね
楽しむ智慧があるんでしょうかと
はい 次 これは悲観 しかし
こういうふうに言っちゃってることは悲観的な考え方ではないんです
現実に対する注意なんです
現実は苦しいんですよ
それを忘れるのは そんなことはないんだぞと言うのはバカバカらしいと
あることはあるんだと言いなさいよと
何がそれっていうのはお釈迦様の態度なんです
だから生きることは大変だよということも見てますよ
見てましょうということで
悲観的なことを言ってるわけじゃないんですよ
何やっても意味がない
もう何でもいいやとか
そういうもう投げ捨てのように考え方ではなくて
すごい現実を言ってるんです
で 究極な幸福とその方法を具体的に語られてます
生きることは苦の上に成り立ってるんだと言ってるんですが
お釈迦様の教えは全体的にどこにでも幸福になる方法を語ってるんです
だから幸福になる方を語っているんだからこそ
我々味わっている苦しみについても語らなくてはいけない
こういうこういう苦しみがあるんだから
それはこういう風に無くしましょうという風に語らなくてはいけないんです
はい それで至福はそれから仏教の幸福の特色なんですね
至福は死後という概念を否定して
至福は死後だっていうのは世間一般的な考え方なんですよ
死んでから天国に行くんだ
死んでから極楽浄に行くんだという
死ぬまでどうするのかという話はないんです
すごくこれは逃げなんですね
もうだから今苦しいんだって
あんた死んでから天国でしょと言えばね
もうどうしようもどうにもならなくなっちゃうんです
それは仏教でないんです
すごく厳しく批判するんです
お釈迦様はそれを否定して
今ここで体験することを示すんです
この至福っていうことは
今ここで現実的に具体的に体験してほしいんだぞと
そこは特別に仏教の特色なんです
もう死ぬ前に天国のことを味わいたいと
それはあんまりいい言葉ではないんですけど
今ここで今生きている間で
この至福というもの何なのかと経験しなくちゃいけないんです
それは簡単ですよ その方法でも後から説明するかもしれませんだけど
今日はないんですけど
それは仏教なんです はい
次に行きます で それからまたお釈迦様の教えの特賞を続けますけど
お釈迦様の教えの特賞
特賞というのはいくつかあります
一番目はソアッカートというのは正しく語られているんですよ
推測する必要がないように
誤解されないように明確に語っているんです
いろんな人がブッダがああ言ったんではないか
こう言ったんではないか
いろんな推測と余計なことをしますけど
そうじゃないんです 初期仏教経典ははっきりとも
悪で善は善で 白は白で
黒は黒っていうふうに
はっきりと言ってるんです
我々にも推測するところは何もないんです
そのまま理解すればよろしいし
それから言葉の使い 表現の使い方は言葉一つ一つを定義しながら
ものすごいコンパクトにしっかりと語っているんです
その能力というのはすごい天才的な能力で
だからお釈迦様はこんな風にコンパクトにしっかりと語ることっていうのは
人間にできることではないんだと
この言葉乗り越えている真理をずいぶん単純な言葉で語っているんです
ですから  1番目の特色というのは
そのスヴァーカということで
次にあるのはサンディッティコという特色なんです
それは現実的 実証できるということなんです
もう神の話でも天国の話でもするんじゃなくて
すごい現実的に生々しく我々に語っているんです
だからお釈迦様おっしゃっている苦しみも
我々には現実的に 具体的に
生々しく経験できるし
お釈迦様おっしゃっている幸福も
ものすごい現実的に体験できるんです
それから本当ですかと
あんた言ってることは
これは実証できるんです
なんだかんだでお釈迦様おっしゃっているものは実証できなかったら
これはお釈迦様の教えでもなくなっちゃうんです
仮定で推測で形而上的には全然語ってないんです
ですから このサンディッティコというのは
今ここで経験できるという意味でもあります
それは 1つの特色なんです
次の言葉というのはアカーリコ
アカーリコっていうのはすごくパーリ語では難しい言葉なんです
いろんな意味で使うんです
1つ日本語で訳するのは難しいんです
一時的ではない お釈迦様たったちょっと一時的な気休めを言っているわけじゃないんです
もう時間と関係ない カーリカというのは時間と関係ある
アカーリカというのは時間と関係ない真理を語っている
時間と関係ない幸福観について語っています
だから 他宗教が使っている永遠という言葉は使わない
使っていますけど 文学的には専門用語としては使わないんです
なぜかというと 論理的に成り立たなくなっちゃうんです
ちょっとした論理のことで
永遠というのはどうやって永遠として言えるのかと
それは言えないはずなんです
だからアカーリカ 時間に関係ないと
時間というのは我々知っているんだから
その現実を見たら これは時間に左右されるものではないんだぞとわかったら
それも一応永遠という意味なんです
でも その言葉さえもみんな使っているのに
簡単に使っちゃえばいいのに
お釈迦様はその場合でもすごい知識的な言葉を使うんです
それからいつの時代でも有効というのもあるんです
だから 2500年前で語られたんだから
今はもう古くて古くて
エジプトにピラミッドに描いてる宗教観念みたいなもんじゃないんですよ
いまだに人間びっくりするほど現代的なんです
びっくりできないんですよ
理解もしないんだから
今の人々も それぐらいのものなんです
だからこのすごいこのいつでも有効的話なんです
だから瞬時に結果が出る
その実践やってみれば
事後結果じゃなくてもやったらすぐ結果があるんです
やった分で自分が幸せに幸福になります
すぐ目の前で人の悩み苦しみも消してみせるんです
だからそれ完成したったらもう完全に消えてるんです
だからそれはすごい瞬間に結果が現れるんです
次にエーヒパッシコという言葉がありまして
エーヒパッシカっていうのは日本語も何か言葉あるんですけど
なかなか思い浮かばなくて書けなかったんですけど
英語では come and see 来たら見よという
では来てみたらいかがでしょうかという
すごくオープンなんです
だから誰にでも試してみることができるという意味で
何か秘密がなってるわけでもないし
特別な人間にだけ教えるものでもなくて
まあ男であろうが女であろう
子供であろうが老人であろうが
聞いてみたら ちょっと聞いてみたらどうですかという
で 解放された教え 逆らうと罰が当たるなどの脅しはないんです
ブッダの教えでは脅しは全然ないんです
罰が当たるとかね 地獄に落ちるとかね
そうはないんです というと
仏教徒で知ってる方々は
でも地獄の話あるんじゃないかなというふうに反論できるかもしれませんだけど
その場合もお釈迦様が言うのは
悪を犯したら地獄に落ちるんだと
善行をしたら天国にいるんだぞと
それは仏教に何とかではないんです
まあ地獄の話を 天国の話で当然ありますよ
でもその場合は あんた仏教に逆らったらもう永遠に地獄に火に燃えるぞとか
そんな脅しがないんです
ただ 悪いことをしたらね
誰でも宗教と関係なく不幸になるんだよと
いいことをしたらね 信仰はどうであろうと人間が幸福になるんだぞという話はあります
しかし 脅し文句は一つもないんです
その代わりにどうぞ調べてください
玄関を開けているんです
いわゆる完璧な透明なんです
誰にでも調べたっても構いません
宗教を変える必要でも何でもないんです
そういうオープンな教えなんです
次にこのオープンアイコー
オープンアイコーっていうのは導くということで
仏教は勉強すると人間そのままで終わることはしないんですよ
どんどん向上していくんですよ
精神的に導かれちゃうんです
良い人間になっちゃうんです
だから苦しみから安穏へ確実に導く
勉強するだけで 理解するだけでも十分です
いくらかもう安穏 心の平安を経験できるんです
次にあるのはパッチャッタンヴェーリタッボ
これもまた大変なこと
そこそこで理性ある人々には各自で体験できるという
これが一人一人で経験しなくちゃいけないんです
お母さんが仏教をわかってるんだから
家族みんな幸せでしょ？っていうのは
そういう話ではありません
で 日本文化ではありますけど
お寺の鐘を鳴らそれで全ての衆生の煩悩がなくなりますようにとお願いするんだとかね
それってでも除夜の鐘の音を聞いている日
誰の煩悩も消えた話は聞いてないんですけど
というか 鐘を押してる人の煩悩もそのままですけど
だからそういうふうな文化的な気休めということではなくて
だから私が苦しんでるんだったら
私個人でその苦しみを解決しなくちゃいけないんです
お腹が空いてるんだったら
私が食べなくちゃいけない
お母ちゃん食べたんだから俺が食べなくてもいいんだという話はもう世の中ではないんだから
だからこれははっきりと自分一人一人で経験してほしいということで
それからやっぱりこの理性という言葉は結構仏教は使うんです
信仰じゃないんです 理性
知識人に語っているんです
はい それでブッダの教えは誰にでも理解しやすいが
中身は単純というわけでもない
教えはものすごい簡単
理解しやすいんですけどね
中身は結構 行けば行くほどかなり深いものはあります
我々は妄想にふけること
伝統的な固定概念に縛られることをやめる必要はあります
私たちは今までの思考概念はやっぱり破って捨てないと
釈尊がおっしゃっている幸福は得られないんですよ
それっておかしいではないかと思うでしょうし
じゃないんです 今までの考え方のせいで苦しんでるでしょうに
世の中は 今までのあれやこれや
伝統的に言われたものやら
社会から言われるものやら
そのせいで我々は苦しんでるんですよ
だから世界が言ってる考え方のせいで
もう戦争まで起きてるんです
人はずっと毎日死んでるんです
だからこの今の世の中でいろんなところで戦争あるでしょうに
全く理不尽な理由を作ったりして戦争する
それからそれが正しいと
また他の馬鹿どもたちも参加して
人殺しに参加したりする
だからこの人の思考に乗っちゃうと
そういうことになるんです
日本の政府の話に乗っちゃうと
もう軍隊はみんなイラクに行かなくちゃいけないし
ボランティアやってる人々はみんなもう取り上げて帰らなくちゃいけないんで
人を助けることをやめちゃって
というふうな話ですよ
バカバカらしい話でしょうに
もう国が潰れてるんだったら復興するのは当たり前ですけど
誰でも言ったら言ってね
もう助けてあげればいいのに
やったらあかんと 言ってはいけないと言ってるんではないかと
というふうな だからそういう世の中の考え方っていうのは
あまりにも理不尽で変でおかしいんです
そのせいで我々苦しんでるんです
だからそれも守りながら幸福になりたいっていうことはもうありえないんです
だから固定概念を破るっていうことは
もうどうしようもないことなんです
必要なんです 破って心は自由にする
それですぐ即座にお釈迦様は幸福の世界を教えて案内します
それから 俗世間が考える楽しみ
幸福も無視してはありません
でお釈迦様だから なんか宗教的な超越したことを言ってるでしょうと
我々考えているこの俗世間の楽しみ
音楽を聴くとか 友達と遊ぶとか
そういうものはもうお釈迦様は無視しているではないかと
そんなことは無視してないんです
それも実現する方法を教えるんです
例えば 「私は金持ちになりたいんだよ」と
というところで お釈迦様「だったらあんたこういう風にしなさいよ」と
私はみんなに好かれたいんだよ 「
だったらあんたこういう風にしなさいよ」と
そういう風にすごく着々と答えるんです
昔の王様たちがお釈迦様に会って 「
私は国を国民を安定させて政治したいんだ」と 「
だったらあんたこれこれこれ守ってやりなさい」と
ちゃんと教えてるんです
だからすっごい現実主義者なんです
はい それで一つだけ 一か所だけ引用してみます
パーリ語が入ってくると
みんな嫌な気分に 幸福な気分じゃなくて
かなり消化不良になるかもしれません
だからね まあわからなくてもいいんで
意味だけね 理解してください
あ ちょっとそちら間違いありますよ
直すの忘れました アーユンアーロギアンワンナン
次サッガンなG 2つ入ります
サッガンウッチャークリーナタン
アーユンっていうのはもう長寿とかね
長生きすること 寿命ですね
アーロギアンっていうのはものすごく健康で爽やかでいること
ワンナンっていうのはかっこよく美しくいること
だから美しくといえば女性だけなんですけど
男性にも入るんです ワンナンといえば
ワンナンっていうのは直訳で言えば色なんですけど
やっぱり男性には男性の美があって
女性には女性の美があるんです
それは嫌がる人はいませんよ
誰でも美男美女で生まれたいでしょうに
まあ醜く生まれたって神の奇跡でもあって
美男美女に変身してくれればありがたいと思ってるでしょうに
そういうのを人間期待してるんです
ウッチャーコリーナタンという言葉
次にウッチャークラっていうのはカースト
すごい高貴 高いっていうことなんです
ということは 現代はカースト制度ないんですけど
ものすごい豊かな 幸福なところに生まれるとかね
東京でいえば民主党の鳩山さんの家みたいな宮殿
半分宮殿みたいな まあもうそういうところは悪くはないでしょうに
で そういうことをね で
普通 貧しく生まれたっても
人間頑張ってもうお城みたい宮殿みたいな家作るでしょ
だから誰でもそういうことを期待する
次の行 ラティヨ そういうことを欲しがるんだと
パッタヤンというのは欲しがって期待するならば
希望するならば それからウラーラアパラアパラ
ウラーラっていうのはもう偉大なるもの
もっとあれこれやと偉大なるものを期待するならば
すごい俗っぽい話でしょうね
あれこれもう健康であって
またあれこれと期待するでしょう
だからアパラアパラっていうのは
この世 あの世っていう意味もあります
この世でももうバンバンサイ幸福でいて
死後でも無茶幸福になりたいという人間の考え方なんです
そんなことをあんた方は期待してるんだったら
次 アッパマダンパサンサンティプンヤキリアーすパンディタ
だったらこれやってくださいと
パンディタ賢者知恵ある人はプンヤキリアーす
良いことをする 常に自分に
他人に すべての生命の役に立つことを選んではやる
これ良いことっていうのは定義ミス
自分の役に立つ 他人の周りの役に立つ
すべての生命の役に立つ
その 3条件で選んで選んで
その行為だけやるということについて
アッパマダン怠ってはいけないんだと
日夜それやってほしいと
そんなに難しいことじゃないんですよ
朝晩自分がやっている行為が
行為自体が自分の役に立ってるのかと
それだけでも人間成功するでしょうね
いわゆる無駄なことをやらないという意味なんです
結果のないことをやらない
自分のために役に立つか
周り自分の関係ある人々の役に立つか
それから世間一般的に役に立つのかと
その 3つ考えて 日夜行動すれば
そんな大胆なことじゃないんですよ
それをやってくださいと
そういうことをやるためには怠ってはいけないんだと賢者は言うんだと
アッパマットウボワッテー
そういう風にアッパマット不放逸でいてウボワッテーっていうのは
この世の幸福とあの世の幸福
死後の幸福 一般の方々は死後も幸福になりたいんだからね
だからこの世の幸福はあの世の幸福に際して
不放逸 不放逸っていうのはこの怠らない
真剣に頑張る そうするとウボワッテーアディガンハーティパンドイト
知恵ある人はその両方のアディガンハーティっていうのは獲得するんだと
だからもう怠らないでくださいと言ってる
たった一行で言ってるんです
怠けたらあかんと ふざけてはあかんということなんです
私が説明しちゃうと言葉たくさんになりますからね
お釈迦様は不放逸と一言葉なんです
我々は朝から晩までやっていること
行為を試しにリストアップしてみてください
どれほど無駄なことを時間の無駄やっているのかと
何の役にも立たないことをどれほどやっているのかと
それできてたってもしょうがないんですよ
良い結果出すためには良い行為をしなくちゃいけない
だからもう役に立たないことはやめて
やめて その時間でいいこと役に立つことをやりなさいということで
そうやっちゃうと この世
あの世 自分が期待する通りに幸福になるんだよと
長寿にもなりまして 美男にも美女にもなりまして
すごくもう健康的にもなりましてとか
もうあれこれ期待通りになるんです
それからそれからお釈迦様は普遍的に同じことを普遍的に語るんです
ディッペダンメーチェヨーアット
この世において 何か我々に役に立つことがあるならば
いわゆるためになることがあるならば
次にヨーアットサンパラアイコ
あの世でも我々に役に立つことがあるならば
アッタービサマヤービーロ
その目的を知恵ある人は獲得するんだと
その人にパンディターティパウッチェティ賢者と言うんだよと
だからお釈迦様が頭がいい人というのは
この世で幸福になってるだけじゃなくて
死んでからもものすごい幸福になる
だから絶対負けないという
苦しまない どこかで苦しんじゃうと
もう負けで もう失敗なんです
頭が悪く 悪いんです だから仏教で頭がいい人っていうのは
常に成功しながら 常に幸せになりながら生きていて
死んでから まあなんとことない
見事に幸せだと という
この世あの世の幸福なんです
そういうことを得られる人が賢者であるというのは
それはこのサングッティニカーの百八十六ページにある
あの経典です 経典の最後に出てくる結論
偈文です で これは日本訳
適当に日本訳つけてみたんですけど
間違ってるかもしれませんだけど 「
楽しみを好きな人々は
この世においてもあの世においても
寿命 健康 美 高貴な生まれ云々を望むなら
良い行いをすることにことを賢者が推薦する」と 「
この世の幸福もあの世の幸福も実現する人こそが智慧の人だと言えるのである」
それは智慧のある人 この世であの世でどちらでも幸福を獲得するんです
そういうことで 仏教っていうのは決して暗い話じゃない
聞かなかったらとんでもない損する話なんです
具体的に 確実に人々に道を教えているんです
全くも微妙にも苦しみにならない
誰にも迷惑をかけないで
幸せ一方 幸せ一色で生きる
生きる方法を教えているんです
ということで ということで
釈尊はまあ次から次へと幸福とそれを実現する方法を語っているのです
楽しみを否定しているのではなく
真の楽しみを知っているのかと伺うんです
だから 仏教 仏典読んでいろんな人が言うんですよ
仏教は悲観主義やとかね
苦しいことしか何も言ってないんだとかね
ややこしい修行ばっかり言ってるんだぞとかね
もう涅槃やら悟りだのわけもわからないことを言ってるんだとかね
そんなのは嫌々だから
もう私は死んだら極楽浄土に行くんだぞとかね
もうわけわからないことそちら言ってますけど
お釈迦さんはそうじゃなくて
現代的に知識的に語っているだけで
ものすごい現代的に お釈迦様が聞きてるのは苦しいではなくて
あんた楽しいってこと知ってるんですか？と
本当に 楽しみたい楽しさでいいけど
知ってるのかと 知ってるんですかね
これから分かります どういうことになるかと
だから知らなきゃいられないもんだからね
それだけの話です はい
苦を楽だと勘違いしていることに注意する
釈迦さんはもう我々勘違いしているんです
苦を楽だと 苦しみながら苦しみながら
なんて幸せだ なんて幸せだと
えらい勘違い 逆さま思考なんです
それには注意するんです
釈尊の教えに出会った時点で
皆苦しみを減らし 幸福を獲得する
あって だけでももう幸福になるんです
アジャータサットという王様がいて
この父親を殺してお釈迦様の友人の父親でしたけどね
で 若娘がね もう父親を殺して
もう大変な苦しんでた
なぜかと言うと 父親がもう悟っていた人なんです
なのに王様になりたくて殺しちゃったんです
王様はあんたはもう王になりたければ早く王になりなさいよと
私は別にもう本人がもう悟りを開いているんだから
もう興味もないんだと言って王にしたんですよ
したにも関わらず いろんな悪い友達の話を聞いて
あなた王になっても 正式的に一応父親がいる限りはね
父親の威厳は消えませんと
いくらなんでも国王にしたっても
自分の父親が来ると立って礼をしなくちゃあかんでしょ
もう王は引退してやってもね
だからちょっとかっこ悪いんだからね
あいつを殺せと いうところに話に乗って殺してすごく苦しんでいたんです
長い時間 誰も助けてくれない
一日も寝たことがないんだそうです
この人 その日から ものすごく疲れて
なんとまぶたが閉じた途端
もう地獄の炎が見えてくる
並大抵の人間殺したんじゃないんだから
それから自分に息子がいるんだから
もう自分の息子はもう可愛くて可愛くてたまらん
それで自分の父は自分のことをいかに可愛がってくれたかと
それも知っている だから頭がイカれるほど苦しんでいたんです
その人はお釈迦様には会えないんです
もう もう会う立場がないんだと
お釈迦様のものすごい友人でしたからね
殺された父王は 年もほぼ同じで
出家する以前からの友人でしたし
だからお釈迦様と同じ年の友達をね
殺しちゃった息子にああどう元気ですかとは聞けないでしょう
その人にもノコノコとお釈迦様に顔を出せないでしょう
だから会わなかったんです
しかし お釈迦様の治療していたお医者様がジーワカという人が王様の個人治療する医者なんです
彼がすごい仏教徒で この人にはもうなんとか治療しなきゃあかんと
でもこれは精神的な悩みだから
自分にはできない だからすっごくしつこく言って
ほとんど強引にお釈迦様のところに連れて行ったんです
連れて行ってる時はこの人すごく怯えているんです
だから出かける時でもこの
男は信頼できないんだと言って
自分が女性隊を作っているんです
そう言うんでしょうかね
女の軍隊 警備隊 みんな女なんです
しかし みんな男みたいに髭をつけて
男の服装を着ているんです
なぜかというと 女性なら裏切らないんだというえらい勘違いですけどね
裏切る時は男も女もないんですけど
その男装している女性軍隊と一緒にお釈迦様のところに行ったんです
夜 夜って暗い時 それでお医者様がものすごいお坊さんたちがいるんだと
すごいたくさん それだけじゃなくて
もう在家の人々ものすごくいるんだと
森の中に だから心配することはなく行きましょうと
この人行ったんですけど
この祇園精舎じゃなく竹林精舎かな
で 行っては入ってはみたんですけど
もう何の音もない 喉が鳴らす音さえもない
それで怖くなっちゃって
汗が出たんです 出てジーワカにもう君も私を騙すんではないかと
もう殺されると怖くなっちゃって
言ったらもうジーワカはお医者さんはすごい年上なんです
そしたらもうまあ何のことないんだと
あんたもう怖がらなくてもいい
もうちょっと先へ行ってみてください
釈尊が見えますよと もうちょっと中入ったら
大勢の人々の真ん中にお釈迦様が座っているんです
誰も喉を鳴らすほどの音は立たない
あれほどの大勢人を集めていて
あれほど静けさ あれを見ただけで
あの王様のあの今まで燃えてた炎がずーっと消えていったんです
体から なんという幸せな方々でしょうかと
なんという静けさでしょうかと
なんという平安安穏な境地
場所 人々ではないかと
私の息子もこんな風に落ち着いた人間に大きくなればいいなとまた思っちゃうんです
お釈迦様は何の恨みもなく
君もやっぱり可愛いところにいつでも考え方は行くんでしょうとちょっとからかっちゃったんです
日本風に言えば 君も結局は親ばかでしょというふうな言い方なんです
偉大なお釈迦様にそういうことを言われると
もうさらに気分がいいんです
結局は君も親ばかですねというふうなことを言われると
本当は怯えてお釈迦様に叱られるかも
追い出されるかもという
お釈迦様は自分のことを決してただよく思ってないでしょうと思っていた
言ったのにも関わらず
そうやってちょっとからかわれると
これすごく楽しくて それであの人のあの悩み
父を殺した苦しみがそれで消えてしまったんです
それからよく眠れたんです
だから見ただけで会っただけで
すごいんです この心の平安というのは
で あの苦しみが消えたんだからといって
罪まで消えたとは勘違いしてはいけないんです
犯した罪は罪ですけど
悩みは消えたんです はい
それでも第1章は終わり
次に何を目指して生きているのですか？という第2章に入ります
何を目指して生きるのですかね
楽しく生きたいというのは人類の希望です
これ別に当たり前のことでしょ
楽しく生きていっていうのはね
でもこれは確認した方がいいんですよ
みんな確認しないんです
だからダメなんです 当たり前だと思ってはいけないんです
私は人間として楽しく生きていかいきたいんだと
はっきりしないと楽しくならないんです
この世の中で人殺しの人殺しバカがいるわ
みんなに迷惑かける人々はいるわ
通り魔やらもうもうもう何やこれやとかね
毒ガスを作る魔故奴らもいるわ
関係もない国に行って
もう爆弾を落としてもう粉々にするもうする人々もいるわ
おかしにところなんですよ
自殺する人は毎日のようにいるでしょうに
何がそれと だからみんな頭がイカれてて病気なんです
なぜかその一人も私は楽しみながら生きていきたいものやということは確認しないんです
だからそういうことになるんですよ
いくらなんでも人生は楽しく生きていなくちゃいけないんだ
そうと思う人にとってはいろいろなことを起きてももう耐えるんですよ
生きているようでは何が起こるかわからないでしょうに
地震も起こるわ もう火山も爆発する
火事にもなるわ 分かったもんじゃないでしょうに
突然交通事故に遭う可能性もあるし
みんな外国旅行やらあれやら
日本国内でももう飛行機で行ったり来たりするんだから
そんなのはもうあまりにも怪しい機械でね
いつ潰れるかわからないわ
だから人生には何が起こるかっていうことはわからない
試験を受けたっても 必ず合格するって約束はないし
だから生きている上ではあれこれっていうのはあるんです
そんなことで負けて もう尻尾を巻いて自殺するっていうのは
信じられないほどもうヘリクツで精神的な病気なんです
だから どんなもう嫌なことに遭遇しても
まあ自分が楽しみながら生きてみるんだっていうことを知ってる人は
そこら辺はまあちょっと耐えてみましょうと
もうちょっと忍んでみよう
見ようと なんとか工夫しましょうと
いうサバイバル的な生き方をするんです
だからこういう文章なんかは
ただくだらない 面白くないじゃないんです
その一行一行の中で かなりの量の知恵があるんです
たったそれだけでも今日覚えて自分に自覚させてください
見えを置いておいて 見栄張らないで
私は家族のために 子供のために生きているんだとか
とんでもない嘘を言わないで
私が楽しみながら生きていきたいっていうこと
楽しむために生きたいではなくて
楽しみながら生きていきたい
どうせ生きてるんだから
いろんなことをやらなくちゃいかんでしょうし
でも楽しみながら生きていきたいと
と思うと たとえ夫婦喧嘩にあっても
もう 1分以内で終わっちゃうんです
苦しいんだから その喧嘩は
その時は喧嘩することになっても
喧嘩の代わりに何かからかったりとか
バカにしたりとか なんとか別にお互い楽しくなることをするんですよ
例えば旦那に何か物を頼んだ
その人はもうもうもう若い女の人がいるところで酒ばっかり飲んで
もう帰る時は全部きれいさっぱり忘れちゃったと
そこでいきなり喧嘩になるでしょうね
それはもうそうすると人生苦しいんです
もしこの理屈で生きているならばね
あなたに期待したっていうのは
私も相当バカもんですねとかね
そういうふうに何かちょっと辛口で何か言えば
それで十分です あるいは何かあの何か看板でもかけて
その人の前に貼っておくとかね
この家にこの期待できない人がいるとかね
それだけそれ見たらその旦那も笑っちゃうし
奥さんも楽しいし でもその旦那は二度とそういうことをしないでしょ
だからもう智慧ちょっとあれば
ものすごくうまく生きていられるんです
ほんのちょっとあれば
そのためには私が楽しみながら生きるんだぞという
そのモットーないと上手くいかないんです
子供が全然勉強しないんだったら
もう君知ってるんですかと
人間っていうのは猿から進化しているんだと
でも君は何か進化してないんですね
猿そのままですよと だから猿には数学やら勉強できんだからやめてもいいよと言うと
子供も別にそれに怒ることもできないし
でも悔しいでしょ 悔しいんだからもう頑張るんです
だからもうキャーキャーキャーキャーと言って喧嘩して
人生苦しくならなくても
ちょっと智慧あれば もう何でも見事にどんな問題でも解決しながら解決しながら生きていられるんです
それにはこの文章もうきちんと覚えておかないと
心の中に刻んでおかないといけないんです
はい 皆その目的を達するために努力はしている
しかし忘れてるんですけど
でもどこかで頭の中ではあるんです
楽しみたいっていうことは心の中で
だからみんなの努力は
この楽しみを 幸福を獲得するためなんです
どんな努力でも だからもう家族のために尽くしたとかね
そういう話はあまり論理的じゃない
誰でも楽しむために頑張ってるんです
家族から不幸来るんだったら
家族のために尽くさないで逃げるんです
家族を置いておいて そういうこといくらでもあるでしょうに
家族は嫌やと思ったらもう簡単に逃げちゃうでしょうに
だからもう世間でいうこの美しい美徳的なことっていうのは実際はないんです
だから私の話ではもう実際のことだから
ちょっと辛い話なんです
聞きたくない話になるんです
で 世間では聞きたい話は言うんだけど
そういうのは実際しない話なんです
あの人はすごい献身的でうんうんとかね
あり得はずもないんですよ
やっぱり生命っていうのは楽しみを探していろんなことをやってます
ということが事実なんです
はい しかし 貧困 苦難 争い
混乱などは増える一方です
人類が幸福になるために
楽しくなるために 猿から進化した時からもう頑張ってるんです
でしょ 洞窟の中でも昔絵を描いたでしょうね
4000年前でも 何のことない 5000
年前でも6000年前でも遺跡あるんだから
すごいことをやっちゃって
もう何もない時代ででも石器時代ででも驚くほどのものあるでしょう
だからみんな楽しみたいんですよ
そのために地上絵描いたり
もう 4000年前 6000
年  8000年とかいろいろありますけど
前のもういろいろ絵画があったり
もう知らない 昔からみんな天文学的に星の位置やら太陽の軌道やら
そんなものを計算 もう調べたりとかしていたんです
それからどんどんどんどんね
まあいろんな文化が現れてきて
消えてしまって 今現代の破壊的文明が
文明が現れてきて で まあ一色になっちゃったんだから
破壊する相手がなくなっただけで
だからなんとか持ちますけど
それでもまあいろいろ破壊してた
とにかく我々は科学やら文学やらいろんなことで文明を発達しているんです
それ哲学も発達しているんです
悪いことに宗教も作っているんです
あれさえなければよかったんですけど
で いろんなことを作っていて
人間に平和できてようではないか
みんな豊かできてようではないかと言うんですけど
一度もないでしょ そんなこと
いくら科学発達してもしても
貧困貧困ばっかし 子供たちが 1 分間に二人ぐらい死ぬんですか
日本か見取り図か ちょっと最近調べてないんです
食べるものがなくて たったペニシリンぐらいのものがなくて死んでるんですよ
イラクでもアフガニスタンでも
だから人間何やってるんでしょうかね
今までの文明 文化 科学っていうのは政治
哲学 宗教 何やってるんですかと
結局は人間頑張っているんですよ
何か結果は全くもひどいんです
はい では 今までの人間の努力の結果はどこに行ってしまったのでしょうか
ということを私は出したい問題
問題なんです それは皆様個人個人にも当てはまりますよ
皆様すごい頑張ってるでしょうね
この頑張った結果はどうですかね
何かいいことでもありますかね
ただ頑張ってるだけでしょうね
何の結果もないというか
何でしょうかね これは
はい 代わりに誰かが幸福になっているのでしょうかと
例えば皆様方一生懸命頑張ると得体知らない誰かがその代わりに幸せになってますかね
それもないでしょうね
幸せになるとか 皆様はこちらで頑張ると誰かの国の人々が貧乏にならなくちゃあかんだから
皆様美味しく牛肉やら豚肉食べるよ
豚やら牛が死ななくちゃあかんでしょうに
だから自分の努力によって誰かが幸せになること
それではないんです はい
人の幸福になりたいという必死の努力は未だ実ってないのは事実です
人類の初め 生起以来 現れて以来
人間必死で頑張っているんです
いまだに実ってないんです
幸福になるということは事実です
努力の結果 ある苦しみは減るが
代わりに新種の苦しみを生み出すのです
私たちのやり方ではもうなんか変で
一つはなくなりますけど
一つは生まれている それは寒い寒いと言ったところで
もう机潰して椅子を潰してまき火してあったかいというような感じなんです
確かにあったかいんですけど
部屋の家具がなくなっちゃったんです
それでどうするのかと
どちらが正しいのかと
家具の価値と もう一晩暖かくなっていたと
どちらの方が良いのか問題なんです
私たちの生き方はそんな生き方
一つのことはちゃんと直しますよ
しかし 別な問題は作っちゃうんです
だから今もそうなんですよ
例えば電気の場合はね
安い電気を作りましょうと言って
原子力でしょ これが何かあったらどうするのかと
それでむちゃくちゃ化石燃料に依存したでしょうに
これがいくらでも掘り掘れるんだ
いくらでも出てくるんだとかね
昔からちょっと常識さえあればね
地球の中でも無限にあるはずがないんだとみんな知っていたでしょう
あれは化石燃料だと だから化石っていうのは生き物でしょうに
生き物っていうのは水のごとく無限にあるわけないでしょう
でも当時の科学者たちは平気でいくらでもあると言ってましたし
それにからかったんだからといって
私もかなりけなされたし
もう最近もあんたは科学にはすごく否定的やとある人に言われたんですけど
僕 いえ そんなことない
そんな偉大なる科学に対してはね
むしろわからないだけですよと
すぐ逃げたんです 逃げたんではなくて
相手にしなかったです
だからこのもうそれで
もう化石燃料使ったでしょうに
使っては使っておいてどうなったかというと
地球全体的に汚染してしまった
だからどちらが価値あるのかと
地球全体的に汚染しちゃうと
生命体は全体的に生き延びなくなっちゃうでしょうに
それでちょっと車に乗ったとか
工場で機械が動いていたんだとか
一部の人間が幸福になっただけなんです
だから結局人間がやってることは
ちょっと寒いんだ その机潰してもう火をつけましょうというふうな話ですよ
お釈迦様が面白い例えを言ってる
もっと厳しい例えなんですけど
夫婦が砂漠で歩く それで砂漠で歩くとも
水も何もなくって すごく苦しむんです
歩いて食べ物もなくなっちゃう
子供もいるんです それでも夫婦で夫婦で考えるんです
まあ私たちはこの調子だったら三人とも死ぬんだと
だから三人とも死ぬべきか
誰かが生き延びるべきかと考えましょう
というと 男が死んでもお母さんと子供には生き延びることできんし
お母さん死んじゃってもお父さんと子供には生き延びること砂漠の中だから
で 答えが出たんです 子供はどうせ体が弱いし
もう持たないんですよ
もう食べ物なくなっちゃうと
だから我々はこの子供を殺して食べましょうと
子供を殺して食べちゃうと
私たち二人が生き延びる
死ぬのは一人だけ それでまあ若いんだからね
子供なんかいくらでも作れますと
生き延びたら 他の解決方法ないんですよ
それで赤ちゃんを殺しちゃったんです
殺してその肉を分けて食べながら
二日 三日ぐらい置いて分けて食べながら
少々少々歩くんです そこで赤ちゃんを殺してからこの肉を切って
三日分四日分に分けなくちゃいかん
その時でももうゴーゴー泣いてるんだと
あの可愛い子供はなんで死んだんでしょうかとかね
なんて可愛い子供でしたとか
本当にもう長生きしてほしかったのにとかね
すごく泣くんだそうです
次の日もその日も だから人間やってるとこそんなもんなんです
理屈で考えたらそれしか答えがないでしょうと言うんですよ
あのたとえでもそれしか答えがないでしょうに
それから泣く そのたとえではそんなに損害はないんだけど
人間のやってるものすごいひどいんですから
もう解決する方法もないんだから
あの夫婦はもう砂漠を通ったらまた元気になって子供作れますけど
我々やっていることをどうしましょうかね
何やっても私たちはこの
もう着ている服に火をつけるような感じで生きているんです
だからこの努力の結果
苦しみは減るということを私は認めますよ
暖房あるし 冷房もあるし
車もあるし 電車もあるし
もう飛行機もあるし 何でもあり
楽しいんです 楽です でも新種ウイルスはいっぱい作っているんです
もう退治も攻撃もできないものという
それは人間の生き方なんです
そんなもんでは幸福にならないっていうのがブッダの話なんです
はい 次のポイント 我々の生き方を試みる必要があります
ですから 我々の生き方を試みる必要があります
省みる  省みる はい 次 ノーリス
あ ちょっと間違いあります
能率的でない 能率的でない生き方を改良するべきである
我々は全くも能率的でない生き方していますよ
世間は だからブッダの教えての人類の生き方にちょっと一つ言ってるんです
そんな生き方は能率的じゃないんだよと
そっと考えてほしいと
改良しなくちゃいけないんだと
はい しかし 人は今までの生き方
業績を何の躊躇もなく自慢する
だから人間に聞けば一番嫌いなものは何なのかと
お釈迦様なんです さて
アフガン人にもあのブスソ
あれあっただけでもすごい重かったんだからね
あのバーミヤンの それでアフガンは不幸であると
そんなもんなんだ 人間の考え方っていうのは
で まあそれはそれでどうでもいいんですけど
この人間っていうのは
この自分のこの間違った非論理的な
この何のノーリスムな生き方はものすごく自慢する
だからこの世の中で あの
受けるためには 人気者になるためには
それを評価しなくちゃいけないんです
皆様の苦しみを素晴らしいと褒め上げなくちゃいけないんです
そうすると まあ常に自慢的だから
もう気に入るんです だから
この人間は この自分の今までの生き方を自慢するんだから
そう思う問題です もういい加減話を聞きなさいということにならないんです
はい で あれはどう読みますか？微笑みが消えた日
ある日 我々の微笑みが消えたんです
で これについて語ってみます
幸福になりたいと思うのは
今現在幸福でないからでしょうか
なんで人はそんなにも幸福になりたいし
楽しみたいと思うんですかね
もしかすると今幸福でないというかもしれません
それは単独のポイントだけです
今の幸福で満足できないからでしょうか
あるいは今の幸福では満足できない
もっと幸せになりたいということがあるかな
はい 今の幸福はなくなる恐れがあるからでしょうかと
今の幸せがなくなるという
なんか恐れがあるんですかと
より優れた幸福を知っているからでしょうかと
まあこんな こんな幸福はもう寄ったことない
私はもっとすごい幸福を知っているんだからという感じでしょうかと
そもそも幸福とは何かと知っているのでしょうかと聞きたいんです
いろいろ聞いたんですけど
で 人間で聞けば 私は幸福になりたいと言うんですよ
言った途端 私は反論 あんた今の幸福じゃないの？とか
あるいは今幸福だってそれ逃げると思ってるんですか？と
そういう あるいは今の幸福で満足してないんですかと
そういういろいろ反論できますけど
そもそも聞きたいのは
あんた幸福知ってるのかと
幸福ということ そこはすごい大事な問題なんです
幸福とは何かっていうことは
人っていうのは知らないんです
はい いつから生きることは楽しむ
楽しめなくなったのかっていう
生きることっていうのは
なんかわけわからない
ある日なくなってるんですよ
その楽しみが はい 次 答え出しません今は
個人によってそれぞれ違う答えがあると思われる
あの これは個人的な具体的な話なんです
哲学的な話じゃないんです
私の楽しみがいつなくなったかと自分に聞いてほしいんです
だから個人個人にはあるんです
答えが やっぱり二十歳ごろになってからはすごくもう大変苦しかったとか
私も十五歳からとかね
みんないろいろあるんです
私は楽しかったんだけど
中学校に入った時点で全部もう崩れてしまったと
ある人はもう結婚した時点で崩れたとかね
いろいろ個人によってこの微笑みが消えた日っていうのはあるんです
はい 自分の楽しみが消えた記念日を思い出した方が良いんです
これこそ記念日なんです
[背景音楽]一応思い出して欲しいんです
頭が良くならないんです
そうでないと みんな過去をいい加減に放っておいてではなくて
過去をきちんと淡々と計算してみて
いつから自分の道が楽しい生き方がぐるっと変わったんでしょうかと
この記念日を覚えた方がいいんです
はい それにより楽しみが消えた原因を探し出せると思います
その時点に戻ることができれば
人の楽しみがなぜ消えるのかという
このカラクリの発見できます
はい これからゆっくり説明していきます
幼い頃 幸福には無関心でしたでしょ
無関心 何で無関心でしたんですか？幸福だからでしょう
俺は知らん そんなことは
ただ幸福 だから幼い頃は幸福になりたいとか誰も思わない
ただそのまま元気で明るく生きてたんです
はい その時 世間知らずでありました
何も知らない時はすごい楽しかったんです
はい 必要なものは周りが必ずくれると思っていました
子供の頃 それ簡単でしょ
はい しかし 社会の社会の構成を知っていく過程で
悩み 不安 不満が現れてきました
その時点で現れるんです
どんどん世の中のことを知ろうとするってところで
不幸が現れてくるんです
うまくいかないんだとわかるんです
はい 次 期待希望が簡単には叶わないと痛感するようになりました
いくらか物事をわかるようになると
お母さんは何でもやってあげることしないんでしょ
自分でやれとかね いろいろ言うんだから
だからもう何でも周りからもうやってくれるっていうことはないっていうことは痛感するんですよ
子供の時泣くんですよ
布団を自分で畳みなさいって
それだけのことで泣くんだから
嫌だということ言いながら
だからそれぐらい正確だったらもう決まってます
人生はもう すごい社会に迷惑な
自分に迷惑な人間になるんです
自分で寝たら自分で畳んでくださいと言ったら
もうちゃんと畳んで もうちゃんと畳めないかもしれませんだけど
お母ちゃんやったぞと言った方が正しいんだけど
それやらないでしょ だからこの一応すごい痛い目に遭います
わがままで あれくれこれくれと言うんですけど
ものすごいショック受けるでしょ
幼稚園に行く時は 幼稚園に行く前
お母さんに抱っこしたまんまで
もう何でもわがままでわがままで
泣きたい時は泣くわ 笑いたい時は笑うわ
寝たい時は寝るわ 起きたい時は起きる
人のことは全然 それで三歳児を幼稚園に連れて行くでしょう
えらいショックを受けるんです
怯えるんです そこから記念日です
で 始まるんです 苦しみの世界
はい 欲しいものを手に入れるために自分で何かをしなくてはならないということを学んできますと
それでどうなるかで 我々は小さい時はやっぱり欲しいものを手に入れるためには
自分で何かしなければいけないということを学びましたね
はい それから死ぬまで戦ってはいるが
いまだ満足したことはありません
それを学んだとこから我々は頑張っているんですよ
欲しいものを手に入れて楽しみになるためには
死ぬまで頑張るんです
でも満足した覚えがないんです
はい 幸福に対して人は無知なのです
結局は幸福って何なのかっていうのは人は知らないんです
ただ子供頃の感覚で次にあります
幼い頃の気持ちはそのままで大人になってしまっているだけなんです
世の中がちょっとやばいと
ちょっと変だと分かった時点で
自分が何になりたい 何が幸福って
そこをちょっと勉強した方が良かったのに
そのまんまであの赤ちゃんの時
わがままな時 二歳の時の気持ちでそのまんま大きくなってるんです
知らないでしょうに 我々の幸福感は二歳の子供の幸福感と何の変わりもないんです
ただわがままを満たしてほしいだけ
だからそれでよく大人やってますよ
だから全部失敗なんです
何をやってもろくな結果にならない
自己破壊的な行為だからするんです
子供そうでしょうに その時の気分良ければいいということを思っているでしょう
子供は それからって知らんから
だから我々もすごいものすごい病気なんですよ
この二歳三歳の気持ちでずっと勉強までして
大学まで会社の社員 会社で仕事
社会人にまでなって それから先生になったり
人に教えたり いろんなことまでしたってもう大変な精神的な状態なんです
大人になってないんです
だから無知ということは幸福は知らないんです
精神的にはもう二歳三歳です
生命として はい したがって
幸福に対していまだはっきりした考えはありません
どんな人に聞いても 幸福になりたいなりと言うだけであって
いまだはっきりした幸福の定義はないんです
はい 次に行きます 探したい
獲得したいが それは何かと明確に知らない
面白いんですよ 我々は幸福を探したい
幸福を獲得したい しかしそれが何とわからないんです
はい その場その場で何かを幸福だと定義する
全くも子供なんです その場で機嫌が良ければいいんです
子供そうです 泣いちゃうといないいないばあと言ったらそれで笑っちゃいますから
なんで笑うんです？あれぐらいのことに
何か訳があって泣いたでしょうに
私たちもそんな感じで
その場その場でああ これで良かったと思っちゃうんです
はっきりと幸福が何か分からない
はい 次 その定義も次から次へと変わっていく
だから何て言いますか
うなぎ弁当を食べればそこは最高に幸せだと言いながら
次はもう酒一杯やったら幸せだというような感じなんです
あの人と結婚できれば最高に幸せ
何とか早く離婚できれば
まあ定義は変わること変わること
どちらでしょうかと 我々の幸福論の幸福の定義っていうのは
その場で良ければいいという論理もあって
それもまたぐるぐる変わるんです
はい そうなると探し求めるものは制限がなくなってしまうのです
だからもう幸福はもう制限なくなっちゃうんです
その場その場の気分次第だから
あれも欲しい ではこれも欲しい
ではあれは欲しいと いや
これはもういいやと そういうことで
我々は無制限な欲を持って探しているんです
はい 次 限りなく求めることによるよりことになり
幸福は消えていく だから限りなく求める
限りなく探す 何を探してるわからないしね
結果として幸福が消えていく
だから簡単に言うんですけど
この論理構成っていうのは結構難しいんです
まず幸福は知らないし
幼稚園の気持ちで大人になったし
それで幼稚園児と同じく
その時その時何とかあればこれでいいやと思っちゃうし
しかしそれ気持ちが変わっちゃうでしょう
そうなっちゃうと無限大にあなたに何が必要だと言ったらわからないんですよ
例えば物語なんかあるでしょ
あなたにこの あれ 何て言いますか
三つの約束 神様が言うでしょ
何て言います？ 三つの願い事
じゃあ皆様に 三つの願い事を言ったら何を願うんですかね
だからこの物語に出てくる願い事の三つで全て結局は失敗するでしょうに
最後に何もなくくなっちゃうんです
元に戻っちゃうんです
もともと苦しんでいたのに
だからあの物語はちゃんとした人生論なんです
だから我々はあれもこれも無限大に欲しがるんです
知らないんだからなんです
あれが欲しいと思うのであって
それがあったらあんた幸せかということは知らないんです
子供もそうですよ 大体若者がこういうことを勉強したいと言うのであって
あんたそれ勉強できれば幸せですかってことはわからないでしょ
若者が医者になりたい
医学やりたいと言うでしょうに
それで我々大人もいいでしょう
君も頭もいいし しっかり頑張れと
応援するぞというだけでしょうに
では あなたは本当に医者になったら幸せでしょうか？と
この大人も知らないし
そう言っている若者も知らないでしょうに
これが人生なんです だからどうなるかというと
頑張ることだけは頑張るんだけど
結局なくなるのは幸福なんです
探しているものがなくなって
探していないものは出てくる
私はよく言う言葉で 私の部屋でも何かなくなっちゃうと
他全部あるんだけど それしかないんだよと
いつでも言う言葉なんで
自分も なんか時々もう面白いことにあのもうマウスがなくなっちゃうんです
コンピューターのマウスで細いペンで私は使ってますから
ペンだからいろいろことやったりすると
このボールペンみたいな感覚でどこかで置いて何か他のことをやっちゃうんです
あら マウスがない 小さな部屋だからあるでしょうに
探すのは探す 時々もう二十分
三十分も探して諦めた時もあるんです
すごく忙しくていろいろなことをやっている時は
それで自分一人ですから
自分で言うんです まあ何でもまああるんだけど
あれしかないのはあれだけですと
そのマウス以外は全部ありますと
でも必要なのはそれなんです
だから我々の私は一人勝手でも人生論言ってるんです
我々の人生の中でも探してるんですけど
いらんことは全部あるんだけど
探しているものだけないんです
面白いんです  [背景音楽]ですから
この幸福だけはなくなっちゃうんです
もうブランドのカバンもあるし
外車も買えるし 家も建てられるし
子供を学校に入れることもできるし
それはあるんですけど
幸せはないんです はい
次 蜃気楼を目指して走るようなものだと釈尊が説く
だから我々の生き方というのは蜃気楼を目指して走る
蜃気楼っていうのは湖で見えますからね
あ 湖だ 飛び込むぞと 楽しんだぞと
砂漠の中で走るんです
そういう生き方だよ はい
瞬間的な楽しみはあるが
それさえも落ち着いて楽しめなくなる
これ瞬間瞬間楽しみあるでしょ？前も説明しましたからね
目の前の楽しみ ご飯食べて美味しかったとかね
ビール飲んで美味しかったとかね
映画見て楽しかったとか
そういう瞬間 楽しみあります
でも落ち着かないんですよ
その時も はい 消えるから残してもらうことに気が行くか
だから瞬間的に楽しむとこれ消えちゃうなという
消えたら困るという不安が出てくるんですよ
例えば子供のところで考えてください
子供は遊び回っている時はね
3歳  4歳  5歳になってくる
すごい無茶可愛いんですよ
一緒に電車でも連れて行っちゃうと
あれは何？これは何？と聞くでしょうね
だから自分がすごい大人だから何でも説明できるでしょ
あれは中央線だと言うんだよとかね
だから大人としてえらい気分はいいし
子供は大人って何でも知ってるなとかね
と思ってもくれるし でもあの幸せは束の間なんですよ
すぐすぐ愛想はもう嫌だと一緒に行くのも言うんです
だから私たちは何とかそのまま自分のものにしたいというからくり考えるんであって
素直に喜べなくなっちゃうんです
素直に無邪気にその瞬間を喜べなくなっちゃうんです
より大きい楽しみを楽しみに目がいくか
あるいはもっとバカでかい楽しみに目がいっちゃうんです
それも子育てよく見えるんですよ
子供はそれなりにまあうまくいってるとえらい期待しちゃうんです
これで崩れちゃうんですよ
その楽しみに不満を抱くか
あるいは逆になんだこれぐらいのことかと
そういうにケチをつけちゃうんです
だから瞬間の楽しみがあると
これなくなったらあかんせと思うか
あるいは 何でしたっけ？もっとすごい楽しみが欲しいと思うか
まあそういうなんとかで不満を抱くんです
だから楽しめなくなっちゃうんです
結局は楽しめなくなる
だから俗世間ではもうもうね
服を買ったらね 新しいデザインのワンピースでも買ったらこれ楽しいんですよ
でも素直に楽しめなくなっちゃうんです
友達とどこかで店に行って美味しいご飯食べると楽しいはずなんですけど
でもどこかで心の中でああいう概念が回転するんです
いつでもそんなものはできるわけないとかね
自分が注文したよりはすごいものをあのあの人
あの人なんか注文する
羨ましいなとかね 自分ちょっとお金がないんだからしょうがないとか
いろいろあの苦しい あの楽しみももう汚されちゃうんです
はい それで楽しみ 微笑みが消えた日の次は自由の消失という現象があるんです
これも今日勉強してください
これも結構なかなかない概念なんです
はい 幼い頃楽しかった
うん 徐々に不満を感じるようになりました
ということで それはわかるでしょ
はい 次 それは自由の消失なのです
なんで幼い頃楽しかったのに
徐々に不安を感じるようになったのか
子供はすごい不安を言うでしょ
あれで自由の消失っていうことなんです
自由がなくなるんです
だって 幼稚園に行くことだけでも自由がなくなってるでしょうね
それで不安になるんです
友達ができなくなっちゃうと
子供なんかはよくお腹を壊すでしょ？熱出すでしょ
もう幼稚園に行けなくなっちゃうんです
はい 次 家族の決まり もうちょっと大きくなると家族の決まりに従う
はい 次 次から次できます
学校に 学校のなんです
学校の規則に従う 友人の決まりに従う
会社の決まりにも従う
それから一つ次 社会の決まりに従う
会社の決まりに従う はい
次 道徳倫理を守る もう大変ですよ
もうどんどん大人になるともう自由の一欠片もないんです
あるんですかね はい 次
以上の決まり 規則を守るために
自分で自分にも規則を設定するんですよ
あれほど規則あるのにも関わらず
自分でも決まるんで 私はしっかりあれこれやるんだぞとか
そこで自由の一欠片もなくなっちゃうんです
はい 結果として楽しむ幸福という概念は
まあ強制退去になるんです
幸福になりたいでしょうね
でも強制退去してるんです
自分が 規則 決まり守らなくちゃあかんでしょうに
決まり守るそうとも自分でも決まってるでしょうに
これ自由の喪失っていうのはそういうことなんです
はい しかし幸福は諦めきれません
あの 強制 まあ強制退去だから
あの幸福も喜んで出て行ったわけじゃないんですよ
だから諦めきれません
はい それでさらに精神的に苦しむことになるのです
それでさらに苦しむことになるんです
こういうこと あれも学校に行かなくちゃいけないし
会社のルール守らなくちゃいけない
社会の決まりを守らなくちゃいけないし
親の言うことを聞かなくちゃいけない
友達の言うことも聞かなくちゃいけないし
それ自分でも楽しみたいでしょ
だからみんなのこと聞いてるんだから
自分の楽しみはもうなかったことにしてるんですが
楽しみたいんですよ でもできない
自分が日曜日漫画読みたいなのに
友達がどこかに行くぞって言っちゃうと
学校に行くより必死で行かなくちゃいけないんです
でないとあの連中殴られるんです
日本ではそういう人には友達と言うんです
我々の国では言わないんです
それちょっとわからないんです
私は未だに あれ 悪いことをやりなさいとかね
来なかったら殴るぞというと
我々だったらすぐそれで切るんです
出ていく もう友達でもなんでもないから
日本では友達は大事やと言って
もうヤクザでも付き合うという
なんか分からない まあそれそういうことで
一応精神的に苦しむことになります
はい 次 生きるものを通して自由を失うことは
生きる楽しみも失ったことになるのです
だから 生きるものとして
我々はこのようなことで自由は失っているんです
だから生きる楽しみも失っているんです
はい 次 まあこれだから大事なポイントたくさん来ますが
もう早く飛ばします 規則は一概に良いとも悪いとも
あ 規則に問題がある 規則で自由が失っちゃうし
しかし規則にも問題があるんです
規則は一概に良いとも悪いとも言えない
まあそれは分かりますね
はい その時の感情で規則を設定する
人間っていうのはその時その時の気分で
もう設定しますよ 規則なんかは
はい 状況の変化とともに変えることはします
しかし 変えないんですよ
なんでそんなバカなことするのかわからないんです
例えば 何か誰かが問題を起こしちゃうと
これっきりこんなことやってはアカンという風に規則を書くんです
その規則は 1946年2月13日できた規則であろうとも
2002年4月26日になった今日でも有効だと
でしょ？皆様が社会に生きていたんだから
私は社会のこと知らないんです
全く坊主人生だからね
一応そうだと思います
変わらないんです これが変ですけどね
状況の変化とともに変えないんですね
はい 次 簡単に変えられるものは逆に規則にもなりませんね
今日決まって明日あれ変えましたって言ったら
何よそれと そこには矛盾があるんですよ
簡単に変えられるんだったら規則でもないし
しかし規則決まったっても
もう時代的に変わっちゃうんだからね
変えなくちゃいけないし
だから規則の中でもそういう矛盾があるんです
はい 次 規則を定める人々も人生の摂理をなんですけど
理解しているわけでもありません
それで規則なんか作ってる人々が全て知っている偉い賢者ではないんですよ
ろくに教えることもできない学校の先生とか
買い物したっても損するうちのお母さんとか
そういう人々なんですよ
会社でさんざんいじめられてるうちのお父さんとか
規則作るのはそういう人々なんです
だから ちょっと目を覚まして考えてください
そういう人々は決して賢者というわけでもないし
世間のことを知り尽くしているわけでもない
ただ その時その時 なんとか後輩になんとかあんたこれしてはいけませんとかね
だから我々は子供の頃
ろくに勉強していないのに
今の子供たちはしっかり言うでしょうね
私も言いますよ しっかり勉強しなさいとかね
だから まあそんなもんなんですよ
だから大人の大人が作る規則っていうのは
はい 次 誰が決めたか知らないが
無数の規則だけは古くから存在する
決まりなんかはものすごい無数にありますよ
あれ 誰が決めたんですかね？あの神社に行ったら二回手を叩くだけ
誰が決めたんですかね
二回でしょ あれ決めたの誰？何のため？でも大事に守るでしょ
だから規則っていうのは古くから無数にあるんですよ
意味もない わけもわからない
誰が決めたか 何のためにあるかわからないんだけど
私たちは大事に守るんです
はい 自分の気持ちを抑えて
ひたすら 打ち間違いが多すぎですね
守ることになる 我々は自分の気持ちを抑えながら守るんです
皆さんはそうでしょう
こちらは入ったらあかんと言ったら
もう入りたいなのに もうあかんと言うんだから入らないだけです
危険だから入るといけないというところは誰も入りたくないでしょうし
危険でも何でもないところ
立ち入り禁止とかなんとか言っちゃうと
そういう 我々はやっぱり気持ちを抑えて守るんですよ
まあ女性の方々でも お嫁に行ったら色々気持ちを抑えて抑えていろんな決まり守らないと大変でしょうし
はい 次 決まり 規則を守ることによって幸福になるという保証もない
では 神社に行って二回手を打ったんだからといって商売繁盛するっていう保証はあるんですかね
家はもう出汁は昆布で取るんだそうということで
あのインスタントの出汁
絶対お前は使ってはいけないんだぞと
姑さんがお嫁さんに怒鳴るとかね
それでお嫁さんも一生懸命昆布で出汁を取るとか
それで別に幸福になるという保証があるんですかね
無数に決まりは守るんだけど
一向に一つにも幸福になるという保証がないんです
はい 決まり 規則 道徳 戒などは確実に人が幸福になるようにと改良しなくてはならないのです
それが私と仏教の訴えなんです
こんなくだらぬ山ほどある規則を取っ払っちゃって
新しく改良しなくちゃいけない
規則一個一個調べてみて
これが守ると人間が幸福になるのか
ならんならん これ捨てましょうと
しかし これが守る 例えば盗んではあかんと盗みたいでしょ
それでもじゃあ盗んではあかん
やっぱり盗んじゃうと困るでしょ
盗まれるのも困るし 盗むことに至っても殺される可能性も
やっぱりこれは置いておきましょうと
盗んではならんということは
もう規則に置いておきましょう
そういうふうに規則をやっぱり改良しなくちゃいけないんですよ
はい 古き良き伝統を守る人にはその興味はありません
問題は みんなもう古き良き伝統を守っているでしょうに
だから 遺体を背負っているだけで臭いだけなんですけどね
その興味はないんです
改革的な人生を改革的に幸福にしようというね
仏教は革命的改革的なんです
お釈迦様の教えは はい
次に行きます それで 第2章終わりました
時間も終わりましたけど
どうしますか？ 第3章もあります
講義 1つは処察1つぐらいはあります
はい 出してください 次に楽しみなくなったの？なぜ楽しみなくなったのかという今日のタイトルなんです
で なぜ生きているのか
すぐに楽しくなくなったではなくて
我々はなぜ生きているのかもわからないでしょ
なぜ生きているんですかね
これもわからないんですよ
わからない それはすごく面白いんですよ
なんで俺が生きているんでしょうかねと聞いてみると
知らん みんな探すでしょ？生きている目的なんかは見つかりませんよ
バカバカらしいんです
私は時々なんでこんなバカなことをやって生きているんでしょうか？と
わからん わかるもんか
そんなのと ということで気分が良くなるんです
最初に自分はどのように生きるべきかを親や社会が決める
そこでなんで生きるのかもわからないし
自分がどのように生きるか生きるべきかということも
親や社会が決めるんですよ
勝手に自分の命なのに
はい 次 自分で決めても
社会がそれを認めない限り実現できません
これはこの楽しみなくなった理由なんですよ
だから覚えるしか方法ないんです
なぜ人生は楽しめなくなったのかというと
なぜ生きるのかもわからないんだからなんです
生きるのがこんなに分かったもんじゃないと思ったらもう楽しいんですけどね
みんな探すでしょうね
それで苦しむんです それで親や社会が勝手に決めるんだから
このように歩け このように座れ
このように喋れ このものを食べ
このものを勉強しろ やりたい放題でしょうに
楽しめるわけないでしょうに
家は何とかの家元だから
あなたはこれをやらなくちゃいけないと言っちゃうと
例えば歌舞伎のなんとか子どもと生まれた
最悪でしょうに あのわけのわからないことをちっちゃい時からやらなくちゃいけないんだから
でもそんなもんで もう社会の決まりで生きて
楽しくないんです 人生は
親が言う通りにやってるんだから
先生が言う通りにやってるんだから
全然楽しくないんです
会社の課長 部長が言ってるようにやってるんだから
ということです はい それもう一つ忘れた
自分で決めても では私はこのように生きてやるそうと自分で決めても
社会は認めないとうまくいかないんです
結局は社会のもう気分次第ですよ
例えば 私は弁護士になってやるぞと
この方が楽だよと思ってもなれません
なんとかという試験があるんですよ
これ 社会が決めるんです
社会がこっちで一生懸命勉強して
あんたはダメと言うんだから
って言ったって こちらが弁護士になりたいのに
だから自分で道を決めても
結局は社会は許すならばなんです
大変な生き方なんですよ
はい 社会は競争システムで構成されている
これから次に なんで私たちは楽しくないのかというと
この社会っていうのは競争システムですよ
はい 次 自分も同じ人間同士で競争しなくてはならない
楽しむところじゃないんですよ
これから戦わなくちゃいけないんですよ
武器を持って 社会と同じ人間同士で
はい 親しい楽しい仲間もライバルになる
そんなことをで せっかく仲良く遊んでいたのに
もう競争しなくちゃいかんでしょ
ライバルになるんです
だから我々には楽しむ余裕がないんですよ
機関銃を持って 刀を持って
もう弓を持って もう同じ人間同士戦わなくちゃいけないんです
この社会は競争社会です
だから楽しめるはずもないんです
はい 次 食うか食われるか
奪うか奪われるかという問題は
人間の社会にも存在する
大変ですよ はい 従って社会を敵視しなくてはならない
我々が生きている社会は
私たち個人が敵視しなくちゃいけないんです
かわいそうに 社会が敵だと
で 怖くなるんです 楽しめることじゃないんです
もう ひとかけらも はい
次 それで孤独になるんです
みんな孤独感を感じているんじゃないんですかね
はい 個人の能力 次のポイント
孤独になると楽しくない
社会を敵視しちゃうと楽しくない
個人の能力 力というものは
社会全体と比べると微塵にもならない
そこでもう孤独でしょ
自分に何ができるか 自分の能力って何なのかと思ったらね
社会と比べるとどうったこと？時々日本でちょっと歌える人々は
アメリカなんかに行ったら追い出されるでしょ
で こちらでほんのちょっと歌えるだけで
あれはいろいろカラクリしたりしてね
アメリカに行ったらもう追い出される
なぜかと それよりも何百倍も歌唱能力ある人々はバックグラウンド
バックコーラスで生活しているの一生
だから社会の能力と見ると
個人の能力っていうのはもう微塵にもならない
もう小さなものなんです
だから個人になった時点でもう楽しく楽しめなくなっちゃうんですよ
社会はすごく巨大に見える
はい 競争もできない 社会相手にして
それで自信もなくなっちゃう
この孤独になることで
もう全然楽しくなくなってしまって
はい 次 自信を持てとったが
もう無責任に言う 言う側にも自信を持てないのにということなんです
みんなに言うでしょ 自信持ちなさいとかね
言ってる人いないんですけど
今まで説明したのは この楽しみが消えた理由
社会との関わりの説明です
社会との 我々社会人だからね
その社会との関わりで完全に楽しみが消えてしまっているんです
はい 次のポイントは主観的な見方
自分の中からも私は幸福を壊して壊しているんです
楽しみを 孤独な自分が社会を見ると
それはあまりにも巨大に見える
だから自分が孤独でしょ
孤独な自分が社会を見ると
あまりにも巨大世界は
怖くなるんですよ はい
次 才能も能力も豊かさも楽しみも幸福も可能性も
何でもかんでも巨大です
社会のもの 社会の財の社会の能力
社会の豊かさ 社会の楽しみ
社会の幸福 社会にある可能性
社会人にある可能性 何でもかんでも巨大
巨大 自分個人にはもう及ばない
だって皆様もなんかちょっと豊かだなと思った時に
ちょっと目を覚まして周り見たらね
ものすごい豊かな人々いるでしょうね
もうゼロをもうかなり飛んでる
やっとマイホームできたと言ったっても
ちょっと外を見たらね
部屋数は 20 あったりとかね
30 あったりとかね スイミングプール付いてあったり
テニスコート付いてあったり
そういう家も 2 3軒持ってる人もいますから
だから社会の豊かさと比べると
もうどうにもならなくなっちゃうんです
能力もそうなんです 全て個人がそう思っちゃうんですよ
世界を見て だから苦労するんです
はい 次のポイント それでそういうことで自分を忘れる
あの人のこと この人のこと
そればっかりでしょ あの人
私よりすごい綺麗だとかね
あの人 私よりは本当に頭がいいんだとか
あの人 私よりは俺はなんとか何とかとかね
そればっかりでしょ そうすると自分ということをもうとっくに忘れているんです
それで夢が現れる その代わりに頭の中で妄想して夢見るんです
はい 次 それで期待 希望
願望 欲望などが膨らむ
社会を見てはこちらの頭の中で期待
希望 願望膨らんじゃうんです
病気です それが はい 次
頭の中で観念的な夢は無制限に現れる
それで頭の中で実現も何もできない
ただ夢ばっかし無制限に増えて増えて増えていくんです
はい 次 よって現実離れ現象を起こす
それで我々は現実離れということになっちゃうんです
これ結果なんです 現実離れだったらもう終わり
楽しめるとこじゃないんです
はい それで無制限な希望は叶えるはずはありません
現実離れしたっても だから楽しむわけでもないんですね
はい 次 怒り憎しみだ その代わりに怒り憎しみが生じるんです
夢があるんだけど実現できんでしょうね
ものすごく腹が立つんです
はい また悲観的になったり落ち込んだりもする
できるわけじゃないんだとかいう風に思ったりするでしょ
それで楽しめるところじゃないんです
はい 次 またやみくもに無批判的にチャレンジをする
時々やみくもにチャレンジもするバカがいるんです
自分の夢に それで次 誰でもそういう結果で
誰でも失望 悩み 苦しみという結果を収穫する
幸福になるところじゃなくて
我々は悩み 失望 苦しみということをいつでも収穫しているんです
この生き方で はい 次のポイント
楽しめるところではありません
これで内から見ても社会から見てもすごい地獄にいるんです
はい それから仏教のポイント
普遍的な原因 それ 2つもダメなのに
普遍的には我々の人生苦しみになる原因があるんです
それはお釈迦様おっしゃっているところで
人は老いて死ぬ すべてを置いて立ち去らなければなりません
これも考えると悲しいんですよ
はい 次 楽しみがあっても
それは年とともに消えていく
例えば山登ること楽しいでしょ？楽しい人には
でも年取ってくるとできなくなっちゃうんです
若い時はね まあ好きな相手と一緒にいろいろ遊んだりして
もう美味しいレストランでご飯食べて
もう綺麗なホテルで泊まったりとか
楽しかったんですけど
年取ってくるともうもうその楽しみはもうできない
そうやってちょくちょく楽しみがあるんだけど
年とともにもうできなくなる
歯が弱くなってくると硬いものを食べられなくなるでしょ
美味しいものあっても
例えば胃がガンになっちゃうと食べられなくなるでしょ
悲しいんですよ あれは
リウマチになっちゃって歩けなくなっちゃうと車椅子でしょ
あれ悲しいんですよ みんな歩いてるのに
だから楽しみが消えていくこともすごい悲しいんです
でも必ず消える はい 次
昔楽しかったことを思うとまた悲しくなる
昔若かったなと思っちゃうと
もうそれで終わりですよ
もう悲しいということなんです
はい 次 昔良かった現象は子供から老人まで共通です
この昔良かったというのは
我々老人たちだけじゃないんですよ
子供にしたっても中学生の時は言えますよ
小学生の時は良かったとかね
いっぱい友達がいたんだとかね
だから昔良かった現象っていうのは
人生は悲しいっていうことなんです
それは子供から老人まで共通現象なんです
はい 得たものも楽しみも離れていく
それで我々は人生頑張って
家やら財産やら家族やらね
いろいろ得るものありますけど
それは全部もう離れていくんですよ
子供がいたっても離れていく
悲しいんですよ それ楽しみも離れていく
若い時は結婚して楽しいんですけど
どんどん年取ってくると一緒にいることも嫌になってくる
楽しみが逃げてるんです
はい 次 諸行無常という法則には勝てない
全て説明したのは 全ての物事は無常であるというブッダの教えなんです
それには勝てない ということで
お釈迦様はなんとか方法を教えてるわけです
そこで一つあって これで結論に行きます
結論 ある日から楽しみなくなったではありません
だから今まで私はそんなこと言ったでしょ
なんか子供頃で良かったんですけど
どこかで楽しみなくなったと
本当はそうではないんです
ある日から楽しみがなくなったわけではありません
はい 初めからも楽しんだことはなかったんです
赤ちゃんの時も 赤ちゃんも結構苦しんでるんですよ
自分の気持ちは分かってくれないわ
大変です 結局は我々は初めからも楽しんだことがないんです
はい 楽しみ 幸福とは経験している苦に対して反対語であって経験ではありません
これただの反対語なんです
高いと言ったら短いというような
白いと言ったら黒いというような
上と言ったら下というような感じで
ただの反対語です 我々経験したのは苦しみなんです
それに楽しみと幸福と言うのであって
本当は非苦だと言った方がいいんです
まあどっちでもいいんですけど
まああの 幸福っていうのは人間はただの反対語で使っているんであって
味わったことも経験したこともない
はい 次 楽しみ 幸福とは何かと知ったものではありません
これが私の結論です で
楽しみ 幸福っていうのは何かと
知ったものじゃないんです
誰も  また結論があります
結論だから一行で終わるはずなんですけど
結論の結論もあるんだから
人間として生を受けた時点で苦を受けたことになるのだと古くから言われていますよ
生を受けた時点で苦を受けているんだと
これは昔から言ってるんです
では引用にします このジェネシスという本がありまして
三章の十六行なんです
知ってますね その本は
To the woman he said I will greatly increase your pains in childbear
ing.女に対して神は言う
私は君のお産する時の痛みをとことん痛めてやるぞと
いわゆる軽々く子供を産ませてやらんぞと With
pain you will give birth to children.とてつもない痛みを感じて
汝は子供を産むだろう
Your desire will be for your husband.男女は旦那に対して依存するでしょうと
旦那のことしか知らないバカになるでしょうと And
he will rule over you.旦那は君を支配するでしょうと
私はそういう風にするんだよと神がやっちゃうんです
神が命令するんです 今日から汝の痛みを私はきつくしてやるぞ
今日から君はすごい苦労して子供を産むでしょう
今日から旦那に依存しているでしょうと
旦那は汝を支配するでしょうと
でも今逆になってますけどね
ちょっと神の命令は皆様とんでもないことですよ
今はね 奥さんが旦那を支配してしてますけど
まあとにかく その聖書にそういう風にあります
次 To the Adam he said.これ十七行
アダムさんにこう言うんです
神は Heっていうのは神様のこと Because
you listen to your wife.お前はね
あの奥さんのことを聞いたんだからね And
ate from the tree.あの木の果物も食べちゃった Which
I commanded you, you must not eat of it.私は君に言ったんではないか
あの木の実を食うなよと
言ったにも関わらず 女の話に乗り上がっちゃって食っちゃったでしょということで
神がカンカン怒ってるんです
はい Cursed is the ground because of you.君のせいで私は大地を curse
って何でしたっけ？呪うぞと
私は大地を呪ってやるぞと
神に呪われている大地の上に立っています Through
painful toil you will eat of it.汝はかなり苦労して仕事をして
この土から食べ物を得て食べるでしょう All
the days of your life
死ぬまで 死ぬまで苦労して食いなさいよと
神に呪われています だからですよ
私は神はすごく嫌いなの
みんな屁理屈で神のことすごい好きでしょうに
はい 次 それ十八行目こうあるんです It
will produce thorns and thistles for you.大地はこの役に立たないトゲばっかりある
何のこともない藪ばっかり作るんだと And
you will eat the plants of the field.それから君はこの畑のなんとかなんとか栽培して
これから食うでしょうと
はい それで これは英語はちょっと現代英語でNew International Versionという本からなんです
だから言いたいのは やっぱり生まれたら苦しまなくちゃあかんという話なんです
生を受けたら まあそれで終わりやと
もう苦しまなくちゃあかん
だから いつなぜ楽しなくなったのかという質問成り立たない
楽しんだ覚えがないんです
だから この聖書を書いた人々を見ても
現実見ると苦だけなんですよ
だから神に叱っちゃったんです
全部 はい 次のところに行きます
苦は神の仕業であるならば
人間にはどうすることもできない
呪われてるんだから はい
次 ブッダは客観的に問題を見る
そんなへんところなことをブッダは言わない
客観的に見る はい 目的を知らず走ることに問題がある
幸福は何かと知らないで蜃気楼を追って走るんだから君がくたびれるんだよとお釈迦様は言うんです
はい それは無知無明と表現する
だからあんた方は無知だ
無明だと はい ありのままに事実を観察すると無知が消えるんだよと
はい 苦は消えて幸福になるんだと
無知が消えると苦は消えるんだ
苦が消えたら幸福になるんだと
お釈迦様は何のことか明るく解決法
負けるなよと言うんです
はい まあそれが結論で終わります
どうもありがとうございます
何か質問があったら聞いてください
はい まあポイントだけでもプリントアウトして皆様に配ってもいいんですけど
これはややこしいし 私も忙しいところギリギリで作るんですから
何か質問とか 話は難しいんですけど
もうすごい即興で質問があったらもう聞いてください
そういうわけで どうもありがとうございます
[背景音]